Дорогі українці знаєте українська армія
яка за своїми масштабами звичайно
набагато менше російського окупанти
агресора дає жару сьогодні цим
покидьками терористам так от і в
цивільному житті парламентській залі
фракція яка має 27 депутатів може дати
порилу Тім хто сьогодні має 250
депутатів І хотіли протягти абсолютно
корупційний законопроект який би забирав
власність і руйнував би нашу
інвестиційний клімат і знищував
підприємництва і за те що європейська
Солідарність сьогодні захистила
українську Конституцію Ось ця фракція
яка має 250
облич тут нових вона блокує сьогодні
права європейські солідарності
делегувати нашого розслідувача нашого
депутата Володимира аріва до ТСК яка має
займатися питанням розслідування
корупції міністерстві оборони А що там
будуть ховати в цій ТСК А чи буде тепер
це тиск легітимною якщо туди входять
тільки слуги і їх служки їх прислужники
а опозицію туди просто не пускають
завжди в парламенті ТСК був інструмент
опозиції коли треба сховати корупцію у
нас Відбувається те що відбувається
створюють тиск яка знову очолить
корупцію Ми хочемо сказати що ми
пишаємося тим що наша фракція 27
депутатів може заблокувати негідні
закони в цій фракції В цьому залі де
слух насправді не з 250 вони не ходять
на роботу вони прогулюють засідання вони
невідомо де лазять але Зверніть увагу що
все що тут відбувається добре погане ну
говорять що це ж Ново не вони це знову
Порошенко продовжуємо гадити в штани
розумієте цій владі Я хочу сказати що
якщо зараз не поставлять питання ведення
нашого представника в ТСК по корупції в
армії це означає є нелегітимність і ми
вимагаємо від сабеля голови цієї тиск
зробити все щоб іще раз і поставили